today on the Matt Walsh show Trump has
unveiled his plan to reopen the economy
we'll take a look at it and we'll
analyze also in extended five headlines
today including the Emperor of Michigan
claiming that abortion is
life-sustaining she said and that's why
they have to keep the abortion clinic so
up and even during the shutdown and also
a couple of famous TV doctors have got
themselves into some hot water over
comments they made about the corona
virus but I think they're getting a raw
deal
I think I'm gonna defend I'm gonna
defend both of them which I wouldn't
normally do with TV doctors but I will
here and today it brings me no pleasure
at all to cancel my favorite butter
manufacturer but there's a very good
reason for that and we'll talk about it
all of that coming up but starting with
as I mentioned President Trump yesterday
unveiled his plan for getting the
economy going again so we're looking at
a gradual process and for for most
people who won't start for a few weeks
and this really depends on the
individual states and governors agreeing
to it which is which is another big part
of this because despite what what Trump
has famously said about him having total
control and power of course he doesn't
really so if they don't want to open
they're not going to but he is the
general outline and in in I'll read as
reported by the AP here's it's it's in
three phases and I'm going to read those
to you but first actually before I do
that I want to tell you about our good
friends over at Bambi you know it's
especially with all this economic
turmoil and everything that's happening
companies really need to need to make
sure that their house is in order in all
aspects but especially when it comes to
HR you know when running a business HR
issues can kill you especially in cases
of wrongful termination suits minimum
wage requirements labor regulations
Bambi spelled B am b e e was created
specifically for small businesses when
it comes to these HR issues an HR
manager salaries aren't cheap either an
average of $70,000 a year for an HR
manager you could get a dedicated HR
manager craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just $99 a month
so rather than $70,000 a year you could
pay $99
how about that with bamboo you could
change HR from your biggest liability to
your biggest strength and asset your
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email real-time chat from
onboarding to terminations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and they help manage your
employees on a day-to-day basis all for
again just $99 a month months a month no
hidden fees you can cancel anytime it's
as simple as that
let Bambi help get your free HR audit
today go to Bambi comm slash Walsh right
now to schedule your free HR audit again
that's it's it's free so you got a Bambi
calm slash Walsh spelled be a em be a
e.com slash Walsh okay now three phases
of opening the economy and we're not
gonna spend a lot of time on this
because I want to get to the to the to
the new segment I've got I've got a lot
packed in there that I want talking
about but reading from the AP reporters
isn't it phase one for instance the plan
recommends strict social distancing for
all people in public gatherings larger
than ten people are to be avoided and
non-essential travel is discouraged in
Phase two people are encouraged to
maximize social distancing and limit
gatherings to no more than fifty people
and less precautionary measures are
taken Travel could resume Phase three
envisions a return to normalcy for most
Americans with a focus on identification
and isolation of any new infections
Trump said recent trends in some states
were so positive they could almost
immediately begin taking the steps laid
out in phase one the guidelines
recommend that states passed checkpoints
that could look at new cases testing and
surveillance data over the prior 14 days
before advancing from one base to the
other governors of both parties made
clear they will move at their own pace
all right this raises a question that
people who are still supporting the
shutdowns have not provided a sufficient
answer to as far as I can tell the
reopening plan you know it sounds it
sounds good to me except for the
timeline I think it's way more drawn out
there needs to be but the basic idea of
being cautious as we open up the economy
we still have social distancing you know
but we let people get back to their
lives everything that's good I like that
and this was always inevitable right it
was always inevitable that we would open
up the economy at some point because
we're not gonna keep it closed forever
and that it was also an edible that we
would do it before there's a vaccine
available because a vaccine if one ever
comes on the way people talk about the
vaccine they talk about it as if it's an
absolute definite that there will be one
there won't necessarily be one you know
there there are plenty of contagious
diseases out there that we don't have
vaccines for so that by no means is a
guarantee but even if one does come and
if you listen to the doctors they sound
pretty confident that there will be one
so okay fine but I haven't heard anybody
who know who knows what they're talking
about say that they think the vaccine
will be ready within a year like less
than twelve months okay you don't you
don't turn around back scenes that
quickly so we're talking about a year or
more possibly a lot more so the idea
that we would stay locked down that
entire time for over a year is obviously
insane we can't do it it's not possible
Society would be totally destroyed in
the meantime and besides people won't do
it anyway so they're just not going to
and they shouldn't they won't comply
it's not gonna happen you cannot keep
people locked in their homes for a year
now what that means is what we're doing
right now and there are plenty of the
Trump's critics that are that are going
going crazy about this that he wants to
reopen the economy okay again we this
was gonna happen
did you did you want to never open it I
mean obviously we're gonna do this and
if we're opening before the vaccine
which we have to do it means you're
gonna be opening the economy when the
virus is still out there not just out
there but more widely spread now than it
was before the shutdown started and you
could say that the curve is flattened
okay well the curve doesn't magically
stay flattened forever just because you
flattened a curve once I'm not an
epidemiologist but I'm pretty sure that
just because you flatten a curve once
doesn't mean that it's gonna stay
flattened forever
the virus isn't gonna say to itself okay
they beat us folks let's pack it in and
go home it doesn't usually work that way
now viruses can if you listen to what
dr. Fauci said he was on Fox News
last night he was he was asked about
like SARS for example and he said that
SARS basically disappeared on its own
okay but he's the one saying that he
doesn't think that's as good that's
gonna happen with this so it's still
gonna be out there without a vaccine
when we open the economy there are two
ways this can go
in that case either we open the economy
and people are smart and precautions are
taken and we still have social
distancing and we still keep vulnerable
populations maybe isolated for a time
you know I mean we're not going to throw
open the doors of the nursing homes
right away I don't think anyone is
advocating that that would be crazy to
do we you know we use masks and in
certain situations and in certain
industries so maybe we do that that's
one scenario where we do that and we
avoid the worst-case scenario of the
virus spreading uncontrollably many
thousands more dying and so on or the
other possibility is that we don't do
that that we're not smart and that you
know people just go right back to
exactly how they were living before no
social distancing they don't take
precautions they don't practice good
hygiene they're not washing their hands
they're going to visiting nursing homes
they're never wearing masks and so on
and so on and then the virus picks up
again and and then we have the you know
the worst Kate the worst case scenario
with the death toll and everything comes
to fruition but here's the thing if the
latter occurs the bad scenario then it
would seem that the shut downs were
pointless all they did was was was make
us go broke before killing all those
people all we will have done in that
case is put off the bloodbath but the
bloodbath still happens so I'm not sure
what the point was in the delay you're
not really saving lives in this case the
we're saving lives things goes out the
window you didn't save any lives all you
did was temporarily and for a very short
time delay those lives being taken and
for that delay of a month or two we have
to pay with it with a Great Depression
and
that to me just seems crazy now if the
former scenario plays out which I'm very
hopeful that in fact this will be what
happens the optimistic scenario where we
open the economy get people back to work
get people back to their lives but we
still social distance we take
precautions people are smart about it
you know and in worst case is avoided
and you know in that scenario then it
would seem that even then the shutdowns
also proved to be pointless
because we could have done that to begin
with so what I read about phase one and
phase two of opening the economy the
first thing I think is why didn't we
just do that to start with we could have
done that in the beginning if it if it
again if it works when we reopen the
economy then it would have worked to
begin with and if it doesn't work then
you know we were always screwed to begin
with anyway unless we stayed shut down
until the vaccine which again we cannot
do so either way it would seem to me if
we're opening up when the virus still
exists and there's no vaccine then the
shutdown proves pointless and certainly
the worst saving lives thing is is is
moot this isn't about saving lives but
merely at most delaying the death for a
few weeks
which is certainly not the same as
preventing it which is why now and
they're not going to say they're not
gonna they're not gonna admit that this
is what they're doing but now what
they're doing is they're moving the
goalposts we are watching in real time
as the goal posts are uprooted and moved
all the way across the field because we
were originally told we're saving
millions of lives and so on well now the
reality is this is an inescapable
reality that we have to open the economy
the virus is still gonna be there so now
they're saying well okay but maybe we
didn't save lives but we we gave
ourselves some time we were able to
study the disease we were able to learn
about it we were able to educate the
public I mean even though the government
originally was Miss educating the public
telling you telling people for example
not to wear masks okay but that's what
they're saying now that's that's a
that's a very diff
thing from saving millions of lives okay
considering the cost there there's
there's we're gonna pay with an economic
collapse for the sake of delay and
learning and educating now I think
learning and educating is a good thing
but is it worth in economic collapse
that's that's a--that's a very different
argument than we're saving millions of
lives but what we've seen is they've
just quietly the you know the people in
this camp have quietly abandoned that
and moved on to this other justification
and yet they'll still continue by saying
that if you want to reopen the economy
you're you're you know you're you're in
favor of killing millions of people so
they still stay with that narrative but
if you listen to the justifications
they're given they've completely shifted
the goalposts all right now I want to
move on to headlines a little bit
earlier than usual starting with this
number one emperor whitmer of michigan
was on David Axelrod's podcast she's
been all over the media you know all
over all the cable news shows she's been
on Comedy Central she's now she's
running through all the podcast she's
she's loving the attention you could
tell she loves it and on the show she
was asked about her decision to keep
abortion clinics open even while she
closes all these other things down and
this is the reasoning that she provided
as we speak in Texas and a couple of
other states I think Ohio may be another
this state has asked to suspend abortion
services as part of this kovat 19
protocol this is probably gonna go to
the Supreme Court what is your reaction
to that you're a governor you have to
make these decisions as well there are
other procedures that have been
suspended you know we we stopped
elective surgeries here in Michigan and
some people have tried to say that that
type of a procedure is considered the
same and that's ridiculous you know a
woman's health care her whole future her
ability to decide if and when she starts
a family is
is not an election it is a fundamental
to her life it is life sustaining and
it's something that government should
not be getting in them in the middle of
life sustaining she says so according to
the emperor of michigan abortion that is
the direct and intentional destruction
of human life is life-sustaining
meanwhile planting seeds or visiting
your relatives is life-threatening so
directly taking human life is
life-sustaining planting a seed and you
are in an in an indoor planter is
life-threatening okay number two dr.
phil has got himself into a lot of
trouble for something he said on fox
news a couple days ago
lots of backlash over this two hundred
and fifty people a year die from poverty
and the poverty line is getting such
that more and more people are going to
fall below that because the economy is
crashing around us and they're doing
that because people are dying from the
coronavirus I get that but look the fact
of the matter is we have people dying
we have 45,000 people a year die from
automobile accidents 480 thousand from
cigarettes 360,000 a year from swimming
pools but we don't shut the country down
for that but yet we're doing it for this
and the fallout is going to last for
years because people's lives are being
destroyed first of all dr. Phil really
needs to get himself some professional
lighting in his office there or his
study because the the lighting just
makes him look undead but anyway a few
other things more importantly as you can
imagine obviously the backlash he's
getting here is intense and on the
critical side of it I do have to say
that first of all I agree with the
critics on a few points first one being
360,000 people a year
definitely don't die from swimming pools
okay it's not 360,000 that would be like
the that's the entire population of
Lexington Kentucky drowning in a
swimming pool every single year and
that's not the case I think he probably
I haven't looked up the number of myself
what he probably did is he added a zero
and so I'm thinking the real numbers
probably like thirty six hundred or
something like that
also I agree with the people asking why
dr. Phil is being
on Fox News to talk about the virus in
the first place you know we don't really
need to hear from TV doctors on this
thing at all and besides dr. Phil isn't
even that kind of doctor he's not a
medical doctor now if you want to talk
to him about the psychological effects
of the shutdown that could be
interesting maybe they did talk about
that but to get him pontificating on
these other things it's just it's a it's
a little bit embarrassing but in his
defense the point he's making here is
actually perfectly reasonable and it's a
point that one side of the discussion is
just utterly determined to misinterpret
mischaracterize misconstrue the one
thing they won't do is actually listen
to the point being made and respond to
it
yes swimming pools are not the same as a
virus swimming pool deaths are not
contagious for one and yes many more
people have died from the virus than
have been then will die in a swimming
pool assuming the number isn't released
three hundred sixty thousand which I'm
pretty sure it isn't so yes that's all
true that is true but that's not the
point that is not the point of the
comparison the point is not to compare
swimming pools to viruses not the point
what dr. Phil is trying to do here is
make a point about the concept of
shutting stuff down to save lives that's
all and he's correctly saying that hey
and this is it's an interesting example
when you think about it because he's
saying hey if we shut swimming pools
down if we ban them which we could do
right there is no doubt that we would
save lives and not a few probably not
360,000 but we would probably save
thousands of lives
there's no denying that nobody can deny
that the two things we could every state
in the Union could pass a law banning
swimming pools both private swimming
pools and public swimming pools that
could happen and if it did happen you
would save thousands of people who would
have otherwise most many of them
children who would have otherwise
drowned in this in those
pools but we don't do that we could do
it and and it would save lives we don't
do it why in the case of swimming pools
what we're saying as a society
apparently is that the death the
swimming pools cause is a price price
worth paying for the fun and enjoyment
we get from them we are not another way
of putting it we are not willing to
sacrifice the enjoyment we get from
pools in order to save thousands of
lives we don't put it that way
we would never phrase it that way we
don't we don't think of it that way
but you know when you're taking a dip in
the pool in the summer you don't think
to yourself ah you know I said I don't
care about those those children who are
drowning you know you don't think that
but if you would oppose any measure to
ban swimming pools across the board then
you do think that the enjoyment you get
in people different swimming pools
swimming pools is worth the price of
people dying that is what you think that
is your argument whether you say it or
not and if we say that about swimming
pools is it really so unreasonable to
say that we don't want to sacrifice the
whole economy and the livelihoods of
millions and millions of people for the
sake of this threat from the virus even
though the threat is much more
substantial even though it's contagious
where some swimming pools or not even
though more people are dying I get all
that but the thing that we're
sacrificing is also much more
significant than a swimming pool and
that's that's it you know and it's it's
a good response and it's a good question
anyway you know it's it's not a
definitive sort of debunking of the
other side's argument but it's an
interesting question
ethical question for them to grapple
with if you're if you're if you're
saying that you're in favor of shutting
things down to save lives and why not
this you know i how about just answer
the question rather than rather than
rather than getting all smarmy about all
you idiot for you asking tough swimming
pools aren't contagious yeah I know that
we all understand that how about just
answer the ethical question if you can
meanwhile
the outrage at TV doctors dr. oz was was
also on Fox so they had in the span of
two days they had both of these guys on
and again why is Fox having all these TV
doctors on instead of actual practicing
doctors I you know I that's a good
question but and I'm certainly no fan of
dr. oz to put it mildly he is a licensed
doctor but he's not a practicing doctor
and he's also through his show and over
the years has promoted all kinds of
quackery so I'm not a fan of dr. oz but
he's suffering his own backlash because
he allegedly said that we should send
kids back to school because only 2 to 3%
of the children will die from the corona
virus if we do that and that's
acceptable to him allegedly he said that
and also according to leftist all over
social media and in the media
this proves that pro-lifers are
hypocrites okay so lots going on here
let's first go and take a look at the at
the segment dr. oz help us well first we
need our mojo back let's start with
things that are really critical to the
nation where we think we might build
open without getting into a lot of
trouble
I tell you schools are a very appetizing
opportunity I just saw a nice piece in
The Lancet
arguing that the opening of schools may
only cost us two or three percent in
terms of total mortality and you know
that's any life is a life loss but to
get every child back into a school where
there safely being educated being fed
and making the most out of their lives
with a theoretical risk in the backside
it might be a trade-off some folks will
consider maybe to get industry back
supply lines I mean things that we can
do without putting nation at risk so a
good example of how this is being used
by the left is this viral post from a
Facebook group for the a group called
the other 98% which is a socialist
far-left organization and website look
at their at their description of what he
said they said there are there 50 6.6
million children in school in the US
that's 1.1 to 1.6 million dead kids this
is considered an acceptable trade-off
for pro-life Republicans now as I said
this has been all over social media this
particular talking point of blaming this
on pro-life personal
and it just shows you the level of
dishonesty that we're dealing with here
to begin with
dr. oz did not say that two to three
percent of children dying is acceptable
he did not say that he wasn't talking
about children he said very clearly
total mortality not child mortality the
mortality rate for children is
vanishingly small so there's no there's
no scenario at all where a million kids
die from this even if we intentionally
infected every single kid in the country
with this still a million of them would
not die and I'm not saying that we
should do that I'm just saying that that
could not be the point dr. oz was making
because it doesn't work with the
mortality rate anyway but he said total
mortalities talking about not childhood
mortality total mortality that's what he
was referring to and second of all what
the hell do pro lifers have to do with
this dr. oz is pro-abortion he had a
celebrity on his show not too long ago
to brag about her abortion and sell her
book about it okay
he's pro-abortion he is not a pro-life
Republican so a pro-abortion TV doctor
says that the uptick in total mortality
could be low enough to justify opening
up schools and from the left that
becomes pro lifers arguing that a
million dead kids are okay just think
about the dishonesty of that it's just
it's it's wrong on every level number
three and yet more proof that our
fundamental human rights are under
attack the Taneytown Police Department
in Maryland just put out this tweet it
says please remember to put pants on
before leaving a house to check your
mailbox you know who you are this is
your final warning of all the onerous
and draconian measures this has to be
that the worst easily and it's
unconstitutional if a man cannot even
leave his home pantless to check his
mailbox then I mean what's the point of
anything anymore although on the bright
side at least they didn't say that we
have to wear pants to answer the door
for the pizza delivery person because
that would be that would just be
certainly going several steps too far
number four the World Health
Organization has already given us given
us enough reasons already really to call
for it to be defunded and even disbanded
but now here is the proverbial
back back breaking straw who is
advocating for restrictions on alcohol
during the pandemic reading out for the
New York Post it says the group called
for measures to limit the amount of
alcohol that can be consumed during
lockdowns
the organization's office of alcohol and
illicit drugs program said during the
Cova 19 pandemic we should really ask
ourselves what risks we are taking in
leaving people under lockdown in their
homes with a substance that is harmful
both in terms of their health and the
effects of their behavior on others
including violence so you have to like
how leaving people locked in their homes
with this dangerous substance talking
about like talking about about us like
we're children the way that I would talk
about you know having a little kid in
the in the house when you've got
chemicals under the under the sink and
it's not you don't have a child safety
lock well you don't want to you don't
want to do that so that's that's how the
the experts over who see regular adults
but second of all
are we really gonna take away another
thing that people enjoy they've already
removed our sources of enjoyment outside
the home and now they're saying let's go
into the home and make sure nothing is
being enjoyed there either can't have
people enjoying things during during a
lockdown can't can't happen besides by
the way look I've I've had an alcohol
beverage alcoholic beverage every single
day of lockdown okay and I'm proud to
report and I have not gotten sick so and
this is just how you do science folks
scientifically I can conclude from that
correlation that alcohol actually makes
you immune from the virus that is a
scientific conclusion number five the
day I have long feared has finally
arrived god help us Hollywood is doing
an adaptation of one of my favorite
books of all time brave new world and
they put out a teaser trailer here here
it is welcome to New London you are an
essential part of imperfect social body
everybody in that place everybody happy
now
everyone belongs to everyone else it's
not pain there John no fear I want that
for you
virus enters a cell top begins you know
I've been watching you people gotta ask
yourself what this place is so perfect
why is it upside down but at the
beginning of something something
necessary just aesthetically that looks
nothing like what you imagined when you
read the book but that's because
Hollywood when it does a dystopian move
this is actually not a movie it's a it's
a series they're gonna do for NBC's
streaming service but anytime they do a
dystopian show or movie
it always looks exactly the same it's
like they hire the same characters that
are the same actors the same wardrobe in
every dystopian Hollywood movie they're
always wearing the same stuff it's like
they have one outfit that they keep in a
in a closet somewhere in Hollywood and
then anytime there's a dystopian movie
or show they go and they take it out and
beyond that just the whole feel of it
like they're trying to make it into
something epic and action-packed when
the story is far more cerebral subtle
understated even creepy that's maybe the
main thing that's missing from this that
is that in the book there's a real
element of creepiness that pervades
every single page of it even in the
scenes that don't seem that creepy
there's just something there and that's
missing from this but the bigger problem
is that and this is the irony of it is
that this is modern-day Hollywood making
an adaptation of brave new world when
modern-day Hollywood is one of the
things that brave new world warned us
about so the book is all about
entertainment being used as a means to
control the masses make them passive
make them accepting it's all about sex
being used as a method to keep people
controlled and distracted which is
exactly what Hollywood does so it's
basically about them so I'm a bit
skeptical of Hollywood's ability to
handle a night of adaptation like this
it's it's kind of like the government
funding an adaptation of 1984 just
doesn't make sense or I don't know if
SeaWorld did a remake of Jaws it just
kind of it doesn't work six finally a
bonus story here but I have to play this
for you
it's making the rounds on the Internet I
don't know when this is from I assume
it's not from the last month or so
unless this sports league is exempt from
social distancing regulations which I
think it should be but either way here's
a highlight from a sport that is easily
a million times more exciting than
soccer watch this final throw of the
match he played well hit some gigantic
shots along the way what I'm not getting
off or not hey I'm good we're trying
yeah we gotta do something
yeah so what he's gonna try to do is hit
this back lip and then cause this bag to
go off while the airmail goes in one of
the most difficult shots in corn Dennis
[Applause]
this wouldn't even be on the mind of an
elementary player Scott Phillips just
looked at Damon Dennis and said that's
the coolest thing I've ever seen that's
extraordinary
Wow I mean I can pull off that shot and
I have because I am a cornhole expert
myself but still a very amazing play and
but I don't know if you noticed this
here's the real thing the real reason
I'm playing this clip I don't know if
you noticed this but the real drama in
that clip unfolded in the background so
I want to go back and we're gonna watch
this again but I want you to focus on
the guy in the gray shirt in the
background so let's play this okay so he
makes the shot he's celebrating look at
the guy in the back standing up he's
going for the high-five look at that
that's he's he's left hanging and that's
that's bad because you know he stands up
to go for the high-five the guy just
what I think the guy the athlete and he
is he is he is an athlete it looks like
he sees him and that's a power movie
sees him it just looks the other way so
it's got my face okay you know you're
not even neat on the court okay you're
not a cornhole player like us but that's
bad because he's in the front row
everybody sees it he's on TV I don't
know what channel he's on but he's on
some channel and now it's all over the
Internet there's no coming back from
that there's no recovery all right let's
move on to our daily cancellation but
before we do we've been telling you
about this new deal we have over the
Daily wire and that I'm excited to tell
you about because you don't want to miss
out on this when you become a daily wire
insider plus or all-access member then
you will get not one but two of the
highly coveted leftist tiers tumblers
and this is a this is a tumbler that is
unlike most beverage vessels this is one
where if you put a liquid in it and you
drink from it it will make you less
thirsty and that's not something that
most cups can say for themselves but
that's the thing with daily wired
Delamar members get many amazing
benefits including of course aside for
the Magnificent an irreplaceable left us
tears tumblr you also get ad free
website experience access to all of our
live broadcasts and a show library the
full three hours of the Ben Shapiro show
access to the mailbag now also exclusive
election insight op-eds and again
there's those two leftist tiers tumblers
not just one but two case you didn't
know what two means it means not one
there's two of them when you become a
daily wire member Delaware insider plus
or all-access member all right today in
our daily cancellation I never saw this
coming but I have to cancel butter not
all butter I would never do that I would
rather die frankly than live a life
without butter so I would never but at
least one butter company that is Land
O'Lakes which prior to this cancellation
has been my favorite butter brand and
there is an IE and yes there is a
difference and I can tell the difference
but now they're cancelled for removing
the Native American woman from their
packaging on the basis apparently the
basis that her presence on the package
was somehow inexplicably racist now I
wanna read a New York Daily News report
about this because the stupidity the
stupidity is on so many levels it's like
there are so many layers of idiocy to
sift through that you really have to
listen and focus okay so New York Daily
News says the image of the Native
American woman who has been the face of
a popular brand of dairy products is
getting the heave-ho Land O'Lakes is
removing the racially charged imagery
that has appeared on its container of
butter and margarine since 1928 okay
let's stop here for a moment how is it
racially charged to simply have an image
of a Native American woman on a package
to merely depict a person of another
race how is that racially charged it's
not like it's a picture of a Native
American woman holding aloft the severed
scalp of a captured settler or something
okay that now I would admit that such an
image would be at least a little bit too
aggressive for a box of butter I could
see something like that maybe on a on a
package of beef jerky or something well
that's not what this was it was
literally just a picture of a Native
American woman sitting there
but it's somehow it's racist wait a
second though I thought the whole thing
was I thought I thought we needed
representation right minorities need to
be represented they need to be shown
they need to be depicted more but now we
need to depict them less so I'm confused
about that is isn't it more racist to
take off the image rather than to keep
it on so what are the rules here exactly
I'm just I'm I don't understand okay
back to the article says instead the
company announced that future packages
will showcase photos of real land olakes
farmers and co-op members along with the
phrase proud to be farmer owned okay
wait a second so we're we are replacing
the Native American woman with white men
mostly and that's the more progressive
choice I again I don't get it
the article says for years the image has
rankled many of the Native American
community North Dakota state
representative Ruth Buffalo called the
image racist telling the Grand Forks
Herald it it goes quote listen to this
it goes hand in hand with human and sex
trafficking of our women and girls by
depicting native of wit Native women as
sex objects okay wait a second oh hold
the phone sex trafficking that's what
you get from your butter package
what kind of degenerate weirdo goes to
the butter aisle of the grocery store
picks up a box of butter and thinks wow
this reminds me of sex trafficking and
how is this woman on the package a sex
object she's not nude on the box okay if
it was a naked woman a pornographic
image on the box of butter I would say
all right fine you have a point it's a
fully clothed woman sitting there now
I know I don't be insensitive I know
we've been in quarantine for a long time
and and and all of that and people are
lonely but if you're looking at a
picture on a dairy product and thinking
about sex well I think that might be a
reflection of some underlying issues
that you have that's all I'm saying
in any case that's why Land O'Lakes is
cancelled and I think representative
Ruth Ruth Buffalo is also cancelled and
also she's banned from the dairy aisle
because lord knows what she might do
there all right let's go to emails as we
wrap things up for the week this is from
let's see here
Ruth our sorry no not Ruth not Ruth
Buffalo this is from Kelsey says I just
wanted to email you and give you the
perspective of a person who would be in
a very high-risk group for covin 19 I'm
a Midwestern woman in my mid 30s with
severe allergies asthma and stage 2
renal failure among other pre-existing
conditions to give an example of
severity for years I have frequently had
to wear masks to protect myself people
at work would call me bane and
eventually stopped noticing they would
just say oh that's just her life when
asked about my ailments did they really
say you're your you know someone with an
illness and you're going to work with a
mask and they called you Bane Wow given
those conditions I am one of the few
people our age who would actually be
more likely to have catastrophic
outcomes if I caught Cove in 19 I'm
tired of people trying to use me to
justify their draconian orders it is not
the responsibility of everyone in my
state to stay inside for me it is my job
to protect myself and it's my family's
job to fill the gaps if needed people
need to take control of their own
outcomes and assist neighbors who might
be in need they do not need people in
governor's mansions to act like the
parent and order all the kids to be in
timeout let those of us who are high
risk work from home and stop using us as
an excuse sorry for being long-winded I
thought my future theocratic dictator
might appreciate the take of someone
you're protecting at home well I have to
say Kelsey this is I I admire your
attitude you are you're one of my
favorite people already in the country
just just based on this alone first of
all there's the Bain comment which are
just take it you got thick skin you're
just taking that in stride
we just got through with a woman who's
crying over the picture on a box of
butter and then here what you are on the
other end of the spectrum so I
appreciate that and yeah I think your
attitude is exactly right and I have to
say you're not the only person I've
heard this from both people who have
pre-existing conditions and also I've
heard from a lot of older people who are
in you know just by the by the fact of
their age including my own parents by
the way you know or in their 60s and
what I've heard over and over again is
look you don't need to shut down the
whole economy for me I can protect
myself I can stay home I can especially
when you're talking about older people
who are retired and don't need to go to
work anyway so that's what makes it all
the more absurd that many of the people
were trying to protect here by shutting
the whole economy down many of the
people were trying to protect by
shutting the workforce down aren't even
in the work force in the first place
they can stay home and they and they
should we don't need to shut everybody
else down so yeah I appreciate that
attitude all right and I and I've also
said you know when I when I have
advocated for a different plan you know
opening the economy but still taking
preventive measures and and I think that
you know there are gonna be people who
have pre-existing conditions or in that
vulnerable group but who do usually need
to work they're not retired like
yourself for example maybe I don't know
if you okay yeah you said you have a job
okay so you're somebody in that group
and I think people like that we should
help I think the government I think that
you know these stimulus checks were
sending out it would be a lot easier to
help people and to do that if we could
be more targeted and so we let people
who do not have pre-existing conditions
who are young and healthy and so the
risk for them is very very low when it
comes to immortality and even
hospitalization we let them go to work
and then we can kind of see what's left
and the people who need to work aren't
retired but can't go because of their
pre-existing conditions now it's gonna
be a lot easier I would think to sort of
target them people in your group
give them help if they need it rather
than sending these stimulus checks to
everybody including people who don't
need it who are still working and all of
that okay this is from Sookie I think su
Shu ki all right hi man I'm a big fan
from Melbourne Australia but I ardently
disagree with your position about racism
equals power plus prejudice I've heard
you dismiss the equation out of hand a
few times before but I think you're
missing an insight that's quite helpful
to the conservative cause I don't see
anyone else talking about it and I don't
quite understand why the argument from
the left normally goes something like
this one racism equals power plus
prejudice to black people have no power
in America 3 therefore black people
can't be racist this is the formulation
I hear often from leftists and that you
rightly dismiss on your show aside from
to being ludicrous as you pointed out
everyone is getting the equation wrong
when power equals zero racism equals
prejudice prejudice it's not power times
prejudice it's plus conservatives should
be clinging to that equation not
dismissing it
it's stating that racism is magnified by
power which we all agree with to an
extent a racist act by government like
Jim Crow is far more harmful than an
individual racist incident but inherent
in the equation is that in the absence
of power racism is simply prejudice so
the exact argument leftist used to deny
the possibility of racism by non-white
people actually states the exact
opposite the only thing I find
objectionable about it is that it
implies that racism equals power when
there's no prejudice I'm very interested
your thought and thanks for all you do
your show a while ago on introversion
has changed the way I understand myself
and my energy levels and has improved my
life immensely okay well I think I
understand what you're saying but I
don't agree because the issue here is
one of definitions right the left wants
to redefine racism make the matter far
more complicated than it really is as a
means of absolving non-white races of
racism while laying the blame entirely
of the feet of white people but I think
making it complicated as I said is is is
the main thing for the left they love to
do this they love to take very simple
and straightforward easy to understand
concepts and make them artificially
complex and ambiguous and
possible to understand because then it
allows them to position themselves as
the arbiters and experts on this topic
and then they can say to the average Joe
Schmo who claims to not be racist they
could say oh you think you're not racist
you don't even know what racism is okay
it's what's too it's too complicated for
someone dumb like you to understand I I
went to college and studied racism I I
know another obvious example of when
they do this would be with the issue of
gender you know any common sense person
knows that okay somebody has a penis
that makes them a man pretty simple but
the left wants to come in and of course
as I've covered many times they don't
it's not like they have a new definition
for man and woman they have no
definition all they've tried to do is
just complicate it and muddy the waters
and convince you so they don't need to
convince you of their new definition
because they don't have one they just
need to convince you that the matter is
far too complicated for you to really
understand anyway and so just so just
let them handle it okay go with whatever
they have to say because you don't know
just understand it that's the move
that's the that's the the ploy but just
like sex is actually not complicated
this is not complicated either and
racism and Prejudice are not two
distinct things prejudice is simply
having a preconceived often negative
preconceived notion about something or
someone that's what prejudice is now
it's not always prejudice against a
person it could be prejudice a game can
have all kinds of prejudices racism is
the belief that a certain race is
inferior to your own in some way so
racism is racial prejudice it is a form
of prejudice it's not two different
things and you notice how power has
nothing at all to do with it is totally
irrelevant yes a powerful racist is more
dangerous than a racist with no power
but that doesn't that doesn't make the
powerful racist more racist he's just as
racist he's equal racism he just has a
greater ability to act in harmful ways
based on his racism but that's all races
is very very simple if you think that a
certain race is inferior to your own
you're racist and if you don't think
that you're not racist and and yes that
means that you could even have a
negative attitude or nay you could
believe negative stereotypes about
groups of people and not actually be
racist you could be rude it could be
insulting there are other negative words
we can use to describe you but if you
don't think that this other race is
actually inferior to your own then
you're not racist because that's what
racism is it's very simple concept now
the other thing about trying to make it
complicated is that we also know the
left not only do they say that only
white people can be raises what they
also say even more absurdly they say
that all whites actually are racist
inherently which can only make sense to
you if you believe that racism is again
this ambiguous complicated complex thing
when it's not if you understand that
racism is simply the belief that a race
of people is inferior to your honor
you realize that the idea of it being
inherent based on the color of your skin
is nonsense no people don't inherently
believe that other races are inferior to
their own they don't you have to be
conditioned to believe that that's a
belief that has to be instilled in you
by the culture by your parents by your
family I think kids if you leave kids to
their own devices especially in modern
America look in modern America in many
places of the country in many areas in
the country where there's a lot of
racial diversity and I can think about
my own experience growing up you know go
on to public school on the East Coast
living in a very racially diverse
community and so from the age of four or
five I'm in school and I'm in school
with kids of all different races and
it just never never occurred to me to
see it as anything strange or weird I
mean obviously I noticed that people
look differently from me but it would
never have even occurred to me to be
racist or to think that they're inferior
because they look different or because
they have a different color skin that
just just you know you don't think of it
most kids in a modern kindergarten or
first grade class you know they're
they're they're friends with all
different kids different races and it's
fine there's no problem it's only
society has to come in and complicate it
and start dividing which our society
actually does do that now it's it's not
socially acceptable anymore to come out
and to you know tell kids that certain
races are inferior so you don't have
that anymore but you do have race
baiters and race hustlers
in the media and in academia and all
over the place who are trying to defy
divide and make different races
suspicious of one another and so this
kind of discord and contempt and
suspicion and everything else which is a
damn shame because if you just let it
alone and let people live there wouldn't
be an issue I think about that famous
clip from Morgan Freeman where he was
asked on I think was 20 20 you know
years ago and he said what do we do
about race and how do we solve for a
sysm and his answer was stop talking
about it
just just shut up about it and and and
let people live and it'll be fine now
that wasn't always the solution but
nowadays it could be all right let's
leave it there all right hope you guys
have a great weekend find a way to get
out of the house at least if you can do
so without getting arrested and I'll
talk to you next week
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we
will get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there